in my 10 years as a minister I've seen
all kinds of producer interests
whether it was the legal establishment
the education establishment the
environmental establishment the
agricultural establishment
all of these groups often don't want to
see the status quo changed
there are people who
work in businesses that invoice the
government and they're doing quite fine
thank you very much
there are executive agencies who like
having power without having
responsibility
and there are also the people who live
in the Beltway
or they live in London they live within
the M25
and they've been enjoying quite a nice
life
they've been enjoying high asset prices
cheap goods from around the world
cheap labor
and they're comfortably off they don't
want to see the status quo changed
all of those people are part of the
resistance to the change we need to see
and as prime minister
I simply underestimated the scale and
depth of this resistance
and the scale and depth to which it
reached into the media and into the
broader establishment
my plans for tax cuts and supply side
reform were about making Britain more
competitive they were about making us a
more successful country where we were
less reliant on government and I told
you we were up to 47 percent
those plans were backed by conservative
members across the country
but we Face coordinated resistance and
we didn't just face coordinated
resistance from inside the conservative
party
or even inside the British corporate
establishment
we faced it from the IMF
and even from President Biden
so my warning
to you here today
is it's not enough just to have the
right ideas
it's not enough even
to have broad support for those ideas
we need to be able to take on those who
resist change and who don't want change
and we need to be able to ensure that
we're winning the argument enough
to be able to do that and we need to
start preparing now